here for reaction out kick founder clay
Travis and fox Across America host Jimmy
phelia gentlemen uh what a grab bag of
stories we have right there uh clay I
don't know if you have your F-16 yet but
if you're not if you don't you might
want to get it uh your pick clay singing
f-16s Joe Rogan
well I'll start at least uh Joe Biden
saying Happy Birthday to someone who was
still alive because we know he couldn't
remember the Indiana congresswoman and a
part of me thinks guys uh that you know
halfway through he's going to sing Happy
Birthday to MLK or JFK or RFK like he
doesn't know who's still alive and who's
dead but it is no Martin Luther King
Jr's grandson right you could have just
gone with Mrs King right I mean she's
married to him right uh if you needed to
so I'll start there I'll let Jimmy Dive
In These are so such great stories to
react to but I'll let Jimmy hop in now
thank you you better you better believe
it Hank Seth uh forgive the analogy but
Joe Biden is the singing happy birthday
as the Vikings are to winning playoff
games I mean but since we are speaking
Natalie too soon
too soon way too soon
let's be clear
hey Travis nobody asked you you stay on
your side of the screen tough guy hold
on a second here uh I want to build on
what clay said because we are begging on
Biden hard the whole country is but deep
down the White House Press team right
now is so relieved he didn't call it
Rodney King day you know right now they
are having a drink in that press office
like oh thank God that could have been
so much worse and that's the bottom line
with everything that's gone on the Rogan
talk the document talk there is no way
this man is running again at this point
2024 is Hunter's blood alcohol content
and nothing more
I think all of this is just incompetence
by Joe Biden like he isn't the the the
fix cannot be in to take Joe Biden out
because it requires so much incompetence
by him I think we're giving like a
larger context to it when he's just he's
really bad at this and and I would just
point this out I think what happened is
somebody at the National Archives
quietly and secretly contacted the Biden
team and they said look there's a lot of
heat over what Trump has and what he
doesn't have we went into the archives
and something significant I don't know
what it is but something significant
that Joe Biden kept they said hey we
can't find this document and we think
you guys have it because otherwise the
the story they gave just think about
this they said they were moving his
boxes do you hire thousand dollar
lawyers to go be your moving company the
lawyers were going in and taking boxes
out no they were looking for something
this is the most expensive movers of all
time and they found it which is why they
didn't just destroy it or burn it or
shred it because they know that they had
to have it I think that's going to be
the linchpin that ties all this together
but I still think they're going to run
it because it's Weekend at Bernie's too
they'll drag them across the Finish Line
as much as they need to
you you used unpaid interns to move your
office so you know a little bit about
losing track of things
to be clear
hexath the people moving my office yes
they're not getting paid to move they're
getting paid hush money for what's going
on in that liquor cabinet just so we're
all on
but here's here here's the bottom line
though uh Clay is Right Biden's team is
not trying to muscle him out of this gig
because right now they all get to be
president you know this whole presidency
is an iTunes user agreement where they
make Biden scroll to the bottom without
reading anything and click I agree and
now you've killed a pipeline now you've
reopened the Border you know and that's
basically what this is so they don't
want to bump him off I get why Rogan
would say that and I like Rogan but
let's not forget the guy is smoking like
a yard of weed per episode It's Gonna
dabble into conspiracy from time to time
but then every once in a while you
dabble your way right into a doozy it's
true uh clay and what's another guy's
name again have happy birthday to to
that Jimmy guy yeah Jimmy go Josh take
you both oh my goodness more on this
Hannity special after the break hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else